the jurgen experience this is your book
about
psychological things right explain your
book yeah it's uh
the quick fix why fad psychology can't
cure social oils that's a good
sign that i had to look at the book to
remember what it's called uh
i was a science editor at new york
magazine i wrote about
psychology basically uh and
every day we get press releases from
harvard from yale from
university of pennsylvania that
psychologists are figuring out amazing
stuff about how to fix the world
how to fix racism how to fix the
educational system and
a lot of these when i looked into the
more there's like nothing there there's
no actual result there and
people spend um hundreds of millions of
dollars on these ideas that don't really
do anything have you ever taken the um
you know the implicit association test
with that no all right do you know
implicit bias
yes okay so this is a test you sit at a
computer it tells you how
unconsciously racist you are so anyone
listening this who's done a diversity
training recently at work has probably
heard of the implicit association test
since 1998 leading psychologists are
like this test will measure
your unconscious racism racism you're
not even aware of
and this leaks into the real world and
makes you do racist stuff
and we end up spending millions of
dollars on it every school embraces it
every company embraces it except whoops
there's nothing there it doesn't
actually measure anything so i'm really
interested in those instances where like
the
most maybe this is uh why i should drink
with alex jones we're the most important
experts in the world tell us [ __ ] and
it's just it's not true
yeah um how much
has to do with when the spreading of
this kind of information how much of it
has to do with click bait
one of the things that's disturbed me
over the last decade or so
is that journalism even journalism at
its highest levels without naming any
names but like
fabled institutions are resorting to
click bait
you know my friend kurt metzger said
something about the new york times once
he said it's like a fat girl's tumblr
blog now
and i'm like that is such a [ __ ] up
thing to say but
what he was saying was that there's
stories that are written in there
that are they're not what you associate
with the new york times of old i still
read the new york times i still love it
me too i think it's great
i mean i think people are always looking
for flaws in
any any institution right especially a
fabled one in times of chaos like we are
today part of us wants to see them
collapse
exactly part yeah people do but i still
think they're the best
and i think it's um there's something
about having
a reputation to uphold that does
force people to the highest standards
but those standards are different
it's it's very difficult to find
unbiased objective
news with a clean headline today
because people aren't buying the
newspaper like they were
yeah it's mostly clicking things online
and you know there's a lot of these that
have
they rely on subscription services you
know they rely on someone
coming along and uh saying you know what
i value your journalism so much i'm
going to give you some money
and then you have to justify the
articles like
you know there's ads on these articles
in a lot of times and you got to get
people to click on them so you have
maybe a title to that article
that's not totally accurate or bends the
truth a little bit or it's
when everyone gets more desperate
because they just need to keep feeding
the beast so yeah
i think the key difference is like i
would imagine you know i never got to be
a science writer
writer editor in 1990 but back then
journalism was healthy
yeah i bet you could be a writer you
know you probably it's still hard work
but you publish
three articles a week four articles a
week when i was editing science of us
that was the sort of behavioral science
site at new york magazine i forget what
it was i think we had to publish like 15
to 20 things a week
so when harvard yeah dude when harvard
sends you a press release like we have
this amazing new study like
great write it up we don't call the
researcher we don't read it closely
oftentimes we read the press release but
not the study itself
and it's sort of like um
the press releases often they don't
quite lie but they leave out a lot of
details
and and so 2010 was sort of the peak
when
the stuff in my book in psychology like
the worst psychology was being published
2010 was also when things got really
really clickbaity i think
why was what what happened in 2010 that
like the worst psychology got published
this is where it gets complicated but
like certain areas of research
so one of them is called social priming
and that's the idea that if i like
if i flash an american flag before your
eyes for 300 milliseconds you'll get way
more patriotic
and it sounds like voodoo magic
but for a while people really believe
these results and the reason they
believe them is because like there's all
these
ways you can [ __ ] up statistically and
you publish stuff that
appears to be true but isn't false so
let's say i asked you off the bat take
the top psychology journals
around what percentage of the findings
in them would you say could be
replicated later on if you run it back
oh i have no idea it's about a 50
there's a coin flip chance
that anything you read in the top
psychology journal some people think
it's higher something is lower
do you have you ever read the stuff that
helen pluck rose and james lindsey and
peter bogosian put out
i've read some of their stuff yeah yeah
yeah where they they published
these so-called satirical yeah
satirical scientific papers that uh
actually the dog dog rape yeah the yeah
well
what it had the most crave see if you
can find the title of their
their dog because it wasn't j it was
it had to do with homosexuality and but
it would but meanwhile
they were getting like lauded for these
things
they were getting applauded for uh like
fat bodybuilding
right like there's a lot of where they
were joking around
about how bad academia has gotten yeah
and they made these
farcical papers and some of them won
awards
a lot of the problems they are concerned
with
it's not just sort of like the wacky
whatever marxist geography it's like
some of the top psychology papers in the
country right i
it's tricky because like i want people
to trust experts i want people to trust
science but a lot of scientists
themselves don't know what they're doing
yeah it makes it complicated a lot of
scientists don't know what they're doing
how so
so um it's hard to explain this without
getting into
into some statistics i'm not good at
statistics but basically
people realize that like the test the
statistical test people do to decide if
something is significant
meaning like we're pretty sure uh joe
rogan comes out with a pill
to cure the common cold we give 50
people that pill we give 50 people a
placebo
the people who take the pill do better
the cold goes away
at a certain threshold you're like this
is a real result this isn't just random
statistical noise
and it turns out there's lots of ways to
fool yourself into thinking the pill
works when it doesn't
uh and that's basically what
psychologists realized and that led them
to understand that like
arguably most of what they publish is
just is garbage basically
do you do you know what a nocebo is yeah
yeah that's
one of my favorite stories was a guy who
was involved in a test
uh where they were doing a study or they
uh gave him
um they gave you know
one group uh an ssri
ssri and uh the other group they gave a
placebo
this guy for whatever reason took a
shitload of pills
and ran into the hospital with an
elevated pulse
high blood pressure holding this pill
bottle freaking out thinking he's dying
um telling them that he [ __ ] up and he
took the whole bottle of pills and he's
going to die
they contact the physician the physician
comes down and informs him that he was a
part of the control group
and he had taken a placebo within
minutes his heart rate drops down to
normal his blood pressure drops down
normal and he's fine
so this guy was convinced he was going
to die had just completely done into
to himself he had decided that he had
taken some sort of
[ __ ] poison or something you know
some horrible medication
and far exceeding the dose you're
supposed to take
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify
app go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience